[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
guten abend an einem sehr
ereignisreichen nachrichten tag inmitten
einer angespannten weltlage christin
sind die olympischen winterspiele in
peking durchaus feierlich aber es sind
natürlich ganz besondere spiele unter
schwierigen bedingungen wegen der
pandemie und der weltweiten kritik am
austragungsort und damit beginnt jetzt
auch unser themen überblick
licht und schatten bei der olympischen
eröffnungsfeier diskussionen über
menschenrechte und neue machtansprüche
chinas begleiten die winterspiele von
peking
wir werden laut unter diesem motto
fordern immer mehr schülerinnen und
schüler bessere lernbedingungen in der
pandemie
trauer wut und die suche nach antworten
nicht nur in rheinland-pfalz gedenkt man
der beiden jungen polizisten die bei
einer verkehrskontrolle erschossen
wurden
ja die olympischen winterspiele in
peking sind eröffnet china wegen seines
umgangs mit menschenrechten hoch
umstrittener gastgeber port mit seiner
wirtschaftskraft auf die globale
führungsrolle während westliche länder
wie die usa die aufwendige
eröffnungsfeier diplomatisch
boykottieren schicken die autoritären
staatschefs chinas und russlands eine
deutliche warnung richtung westen über
die politische provokation und die
eröffnung der spiele christiane hoffmann
aus peking
jedes land eine einzelne schneeflocke
sie vereinen sich zu einer großen in
frieden und einheit eine inszenierung
der macher der eröffnungsfeier wie auch
die einheit der minderheiten unter
chinas fahrner diese einheit ist vor
allem in hongkong china und tibet
militärisch erzwungenen massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen die die
olympischen spiele überschatten auch
deshalb boykottieren die usa
großbritannien und andere staaten die
spiele diplomatisch auch deutschland
bleibt fern
dennoch sollen es winterspiele der
superlative werden dafür wurden dörfer
umgesiedelt riesige sportstätten in die
berge gebaut und ein naturschutzgebiet
zerstört überschattet sind die spiele
auch von der korona pandemie die
olympia-teilnehmer abgeschottet sollen
keinen kontakt zur bevölkerung haben die
korona maßnahmen selbst trägt auch im
olympiastadion müssen alle geimpft und
getestet sein dennoch wurden schon mehr
als 300 olympia-teilnehmer corona
positiv getestet angesichts weltweiter
konflikte fordert ioc präsident bach die
welt zum frieden auf
halten sie sich an ihr versprechen des
olympischen waffenstillstands geben sie
dem frieden eine chance
eine botschaft vielleicht auch an
präsident ski und russlands staatschef
putin kurz vorher hatten sie
demonstrativ der welt ihre einigkeit
präsentiert und gefordert dass es keine
nato erweiterung mehr gibt es entwickle
sich eine strategische partnerschaft mit
china in nie dagewesener weise so putin
russland und china im schulterschluss
gegen den westen ein widerspruch zu den
600 kindern die friedenstauben schwenken
zusammen für eine gemeinsame zukunft das
motto dieser olympischen winterspiele
die politischen signale sprechen eine
andere sprache
zur einordnung wollen wir nachfragen bei
ulf röller in peking ulf bei den spielen
2008 wollte china zeigen mit uns müsst
ihr in zukunft zu rechnen welche
botschaft geht denn jetzt von peking aus
2008 war china noch ein land das an
seiner eigenen stärke eigentlich
zweifelte unsicher aber jetzt ist das
völlige gegenteil man kann eigentlich
vor politischer kraft kaum laufen
man fühlt sich als weltmacht auf
augenhöhe von den amerikanern und
deshalb hat man diese feier relativ
bescheiden dargestellt man braucht kein
nationales pathos sondern man hat sehr
viele botschaften ausgesendet richtung
frieden und präsident ski hat sich
inszeniert als der große welten kümmer
der eine nation anführt die für frieden
ist dass dies natürlich eine optische
täuschung gewesen ist sieht man wenn man
die international lage sich anschaut wie
habe es gerade gehört vor der eröffnung
haben chinas und russlands präsidenten
den westen gewarnt da sind den westen
der russland im ukraine konflikt die
stirn bieten will was hat chinas
präsident vor
das ist das andere gesicht von präsident
ski dass es das gesicht eines mannes der
einen großen machtwillen hat er hat
quasi die sache ausgenutzt dass die
ganze welt auf peking guckte wegen der
olympischen spiele um sich eben mit
putin zu treffen und quasi die muskeln
spielen zu lassen richtung westen man
hat ein schulterschluss gemacht und die
nato mehr oder weniger ganz klar gesagt
wenn ihr weiter geht dann wird das
gefährlich schiebe das machen um
deutlich zu zeigen dass es dieses
bündnis gibt dass es eine neue achse
gibt zwischen moskau und peking die sich
gegen washington richtet und das hat
dann mit dem olympischen geist
eigentlich wenig zu tun das ist der
geist der realität der zurzeit durch die
weltweit dankeschön für die einordnung
nach peking um früh haben wir kommen
später auf dieses thema noch mal zurück
wie es jetzt weitergeht bei olympia in
sachen corona politisch und natürlich
auch sportlich das können sie in unserer
zdf heute app verfolgen zum beispiel wie
die sportstätten bei den biathleten
ankommen oder wann welche wettbewerbe
stattfinden
und später ist nämlich jetzt wir haben
es gerade thematisiert china und
russland war die nato vor erweiterung
die ukraine krise schwelt weiter und
inmitten dieser heiklen phase wird heute
bekannt dass nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg im herbst ausscheidet und
neuer chef der norwegischen zentralbank
wird also nachgefragt jetzt bei unserem
brüssel korrespondenten bei florian hahn
jetzt gibt sich neben russland auch das
mächtige china offensiv als nato gegner
was bedeutet da der abgang von
stoltenberg
stoltenberg ist das gesicht der nato in
dieser krise und es verginge zuletzt
kaum einen tag an dem er nicht mit
relativ scharfen worten vor an dem
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine
gewarnt insofern ist der zeitpunkt
dieser ankündigung schon etwas misslich
dass er mitten in dieser krise eben dann
abschied ankündigte
andererseits war eben dieser abschied
lange bekannt dass seine amtszeit seine
dritte amtszeit im herbst enden würde
war bekannt und dass er interesse an
diesem job in norwegen hatte ebenso und
schließlich ist ein nato general
sekretär auch keinen general der einen
kurs vorgibt wie stark die nato ist
hängt vor allem davon ab wie stark die
30 nato staaten zusammenarbeiten und da
erleben wir gerade dass die russischen
drohungen die 30 staaten wieder enger
zusammenrücken lassen die neue russisch
chinesische allianz die könnte diesen
effekt womöglich sogar noch verstärken
vielen dank nach brüssel florian leu hat
ja in der anhaltenden ukraine krise
wollen zwei wichtige europäische
regierungschefs eine art diplomatie
turbo anschmeißen erst reist frankreichs
präsident ma con kommende woche zu
vermittlungsgesprächen nach kiew und
moskau bundeskanzler scholz wird es ihm
mitte februar gleich tun zuvor also am
kommenden montag trifft der kanzler den
us-präsidenten und mitten in alle
diplomatischen bemühungen platzt eine
warnung aus dem pentagon ein sprecher
des amerikanischen militärs erklärt
moskau arbeite an einem propagandavideo
es solle einen vorwand liefern für einen
möglichen einmarsch der russen in die
ukraine das zeigten
geheimdienstinformationen dazu aus
washington claudia beitsch
us soldaten kommen in polen an russland
und die usa werfen sich gegenseitig
eskalation vor jetzt angeblich neue us
geheimdienstinformationen russland
erwäge einen angriff auf die eigenen
leute zu inszenieren für den dann die
ukraine verantwortlich gemacht werden
soll pentagon sprecher john curry mit
details
als teil dieses schein angriffs glauben
wir dass russland ein sehr drastisches
video produzieren würde das laichen
zeigen würde schauspieler die trauernde
spielen zerstörte orte und waffen aus
der ukraine oder dem westen
in der pressekonferenz des
außenministeriums drängen journalisten
auf belege es handele sich schließlich
um ernste und erstaunliche vorwürfe
wenn sie keine beweise haben außer ich
sage es also stimmt es dann ist das ein
problem
wir leiten das aus geheimdienst-
informationen ab denen wir vertrauen
andernfalls würden wir es nicht in
dieser weise veröffentlichen
der kreml erklärt den vorwurf eines
vorgetäuschten angriffs für unsinn
also ich weiß nicht das ist aus
gedachter quatsch mehr und mehr jeden
tag das müsste jeder erfahrene
politikwissenschaftler erkennen
doch russische militärübungen nahe der
ukrainischen grenze gehen weiter keine
die eskalation die us regierung sagt mit
der veröffentlichung wolle man
verhindern dass das beschriebene
szenario von russland umgesetzt werden
könne
jetzt zu corona keine zu schnellen
lockerungen warnen intensivmediziner der
präsident des verbandes gernot maas
sagte der funker mediengruppe bund und
länder sollen damit warten bis die
infektionszahlen stabil über mehrere
tage zurück gehen das robert koch
institut registrierte
248 1838 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages 58 1690 mehr als vor einer
woche
170 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage incidents steigt
jetzt auf 1300
49,5
corona rollt nahezu ungebremst durch
deutsche klassenzimmer das belegen
aktuelle zahlen der
kultusministerkonferenz
allein in der vergangenen woche waren
rund 500.000 kinder und jugendliche an
corona erkrankt oder in quarantäne das
sind rund fünf prozent aller schüler in
einem offenen brief beklagen
schülersprecher jetzt dass die politik
sie im stich lasse
mehr über die aktion hashtag wir werden
laut von petra neubauer
es sind schwierige zeiten an den schulen
zwei jahre einschränkungen durch corona
viele sehen sich an der belastungsgrenze
fühlen sich von der politik vergessen
für año kino aus berlin ist das maß nun
voll wir haben uns die letzten zwei
jahre zurückgenommen damit andere
personen in sicherheit wiegen können und
gleichzeitig verpassen wir einfach die
wichtigsten jahr in unserem leben so hat
sich an jung mit mehr als 100 schüler
und schülerinnen vertreter aus ganz
deutschland in einem offenen brief an
die politik gewandt unter dem hashtag
wir werden laut fordern sie unter
anderem luftfilter an allen schulen
kostenlose ffp zwei masken pcr tests und
sie sprechen sich gegen eine
präsenzpflicht aus heißt schüler innen
und eltern sollen selbst entscheiden
welche art der beschulung passt doch
dieser punkt ist umstritten kinder und
jugendliche brauchen unbedingt ihr
soziales umfeld die brauchen schule sie
brauchen ihre mitschülerinnen mitschüler
und auch ihre lehrer im direkten
sozialen kontakt und deshalb wäre es
falsch dass den eltern im einzelfall zu
überlassen die korona pandemie und ihre
folgen sind vor allem in den
abschlussklassen spürbar das aufbegehren
verständlich sagt der psychologe diese
schüler und schülerinnen sehen natürlich
das von ihnen etwas erwartet wird dass
sie einfach nicht
leisten können das ja auch modrig zum
teil nicht vermittelt
eines hat der brief schon jetzt bewirbt
die politik hat die initiatoren der
aktion via new kino zum gespräch geladen
vor vier tagen fielen die tödlichen
schüsse auf zwei junge polizisten im
rheinland pfälzischen kusel heute
gedachten an vielen orten in ganz
deutschland beamte politiker und bürger
mit einer schweigeminute der beiden
opfer und noch immer herrscht
fassungslosigkeit darüber dass sie
sterben mussten weil sie offenbar zwei
männer nach wilderei entdeckt hatten
susanne gelhard berichtet
für jasmin 24 und alexander 29 jahre
kirchenleuten und eine schweigeminute
auch in mainz in kusel kamen kolleginnen
kollegen und angehörige zu einer nicht
öffentlichen gedenkfeier zusammen raum
für trauer und erinnerung
diese morde machen uns fassungslos
weil jasmin und alex für uns nicht nur
kollegen waren sondern freunde
wegbegleiter
partner beim sport das ganze leben
miteinander gelebt haben hier wurden die
beamten mit jagdwaffen brutal ermordet
einer der zwei verdächtigen wurde wegen
körperverletzung bereits vor jahren
verurteilt gegen beide wurde unter
anderem wegen wilderei mehrfach
ermittelt nach den morgen gibt es breite
solidarität mit den opfern aber nicht
nur das wir erleben im netz gerade
widerwärtige dinge dass diese tat von
manchen bejubelt wird das ist einfach
nur menschenverachtend und schlimm wir
werden bestrafen und alle mittel des
rechtsstaates nutzen um das tatsächlich
dann auch zur strafe zu bringen einer
neu eingerichteten ermittlergruppe gegen
hass im netz gelang in der vergangenen
nacht im raum idar oberstein bereits ein
zugriff dort hatte eine person im netz
aufgerufen
polizeibeamtin polizeibeamte auf
feldwege zu locken und sie dort zu
beschießen haben heute nacht diese
wohnung geöffnet den hauptverdächtigen
überwältigt und das verfahren läuft ein
tag des gedenkens auch vor der
polizeiwache in kusel jasmin und alex im
einsatz waren
dieser heutige freitag ist weltkrebstag
in deutschland erkranken jährlich etwa
500.000 menschen an krebs 2020 waren
rund 1,45 millionen patienten in
stationärer behandlung 6 prozent weniger
im vergleich zum vorjahr die gründe laut
deutscher krebshilfe weniger
früherkennung und verschobene
operationen wegen corona aber es gibt
auch gute nachrichten deutsche forscher
machen jetzt hirntumorpatienten hoffnung
mit einer neuen therapie mehr dazu von
moritz neuss
christopher michels auf dem weg ins
mannheimer krankenhaus der 29 jährige
hat einen hirntumore bestrahlung und
chemotherapie schlagen nicht an als er
das angebot bekommt an einer studie für
eine behandlung mit einem impfstoff
teilzunehmen zögert er nicht seitdem
wird der bwl-student alle drei monate
die scan to me but i ist man immer ein
bisschen angespannt was dann an den
bildern danach zur kenntnis aber
bisher zumindest bei mir sitzt alles
stabil und dann ist es auch wieder so
ein glücksgefühl michels tumor sitzt
mitten im gehirn eine op quasi unmöglich
durch die impfung wird dem immunsystem
beigebracht den tumor selbst zu erkennen
und zu bekämpfen dafür bekommt er
regelmäßig eine spritze studienleiter
michael platten erkennt einen kleinen
fortschritt er ist nicht weg aber wir
sehen doch dass es zu einem rückgang
gekommen ist und das ist im rahmen der
studie tatsächlich ein sehr schöner
erfolg vor allen dingen für mich jetzt
auch die bochumer uni klinik nimmt an
verschiedenen studien zur behandlung von
krebs teil dort betrachten sie die
impfstudie als durchbruch die
impfstrategie gegen hirntumoren ist eine
neue vielversprechende strategie etwas
vergleichbares gibt es in den usa in
china und auch sonst auf der welt nicht
an hochinnovativen krebstherapien wird
weltweit geforscht mit der m rna
technologie nährt auch das mainzer
unternehmen bei und tag die hoffnung auf
den nächsten medizinischen fortschritt
bei individualisierten krebsimpfstoffen
bis die breit eingesetzt werden können
kann es noch einige jahre dauern für
christopher michels aber hat sich schon
jetzt viel verändert
mehrere lawinenunglücke heute in
österreich bei einem abgang in tirol
sind fünf menschen ums leben gekommen
das unglück ereignete sich bei spies
nahe der grenze zur schweiz von einer
weiteren lawine nahe sölden wurden am
morgen fünf menschen erfasst vier von
ihnen mussten verletzt ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden
das containerschiff das vor der
nordseeinsel wangerooge auf grund
gelaufen war ist wieder frei im zweiten
anlauf hat es mit der bergung geklappt
weder rumpf noch maschinen des fast 400
meter langen frachters sollen beschädigt
sein in der nacht hatten gleich neun
schlepper gemeinsam die mum beiden märz
bei maximalem hochwasser vom grund
gezogen inzwischen hat das schiff unter
dänischer flagge die freigabe zur
weiterfahrt
und wir sind wieder bei den olympischen
spielen und ihr christen und kommen noch
mal zur eröffnungsfeier angeführt von
claudia pechstein und francesco
friedrich lief ein teil der deutschen
olympiamannschaft recht fröhlich ins
vogelnest dem nationalstadion von peking
ein für die sportlerinnen und sportler
stets etwas ganz besonderes es ist der
grosse moment für die eisschnellläuferin
und rekord teilnehmerin claudia
pechstein bei ihren acht olympischen
spielen darf sie die deutsche delegation
in das vogelnest stadion in peking
anführen gemeinsam mit bob olympiasieger
francesco friedrich ein besonderer
moment für die 49 jährige
[Musik]
und so hören gedauert und mandy
der fahnenträger von 2018 meldete leider
negatives mit favorit bei den nordisch
kombinierer eric frenzel wurde positiv
auf corona getestet genauso wie
teamkollege terence weber apropos corona
skispringerin katharina althaus hat
morgen sehr gute chancen auf erstes
edelmetall für deutschland weil die
österreichische gold-hoffnung maria
kramer corona bedingt passen muss
und das ist nicht althaus einzige chance
vielleicht gelingt eine weitere medaille
bei der olympia premiere im mixed team
wettbewerb am montag
ja am heutigen tag der eröffnungsfeier
also noch keine olympischen
entscheidungen aber vorkämpfe zb im
eiskunstlaufen der team wettbewerb eine
äußerst schwierige aufgabe für die
deutschen die den corona schock nicht
kompensieren konnten we miss you wir
vermissen euch der aufmunternde große
anzahl an segert und seine partnerin die
wegen segatz corona infektion nicht
starten konnten allein deshalb
deutschland chancenlos zudem patzte paul
fans bei den sprüngen und auf den
eistänzer katharina müller und andy
unterliefen fehler die deutschen im
zwischenklassement letzte im führung
momentan das team usa vor allem dank
weltmeister nation chen der auch im
einzel gold anpeilt lauteste
konkurrenten um team-gold die russen nur
knapp hinter den usa
einer starken laufleistung schoben sich
die chinesischen gastgeber auf rang drei
freuen wir uns auf morgen da gibt's die
ersten medaillen ja nicht mit alldem
verdächtig das wetter dankeschön
christine bleibt nämlich ungemütlich
heute nacht dafür wird es dann morgen
aber wieder freundlicher mehr gleich von
katja horneffer ab 22 uhr empfehlen wir
das heute journal mit bettina schausten
dann sagen wir kommen sie gut ins
wochenende machen sich einen schönen
entspannten abend und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend die kaltfront von tief wie
nah die zieht schon in der nacht aus
deutschland raus dann kommt das hoch
holm und am sonntag schon gleich das
nächste stürmische tiefen nämlich roxana
heute nacht überquerten es erstmal die
kaltfront da fällt kräftiger regen es
ist doch schnee dabei in den
mittelgebirgen am alpenrand aber auch in
norddeutschland auch morgen vormittag
kann es noch einige schneeregenschauer
hier im nordosten geben dann wird das
ein sehr trockener samstag bevor dann
zum späten nachmittag dichtere wolken
mit regen von der nordsee küste heran
gekommen machen sie sich heute nacht
auch auf starken bis stürmischen
südwestwind gefasst hinter der kaltfront
dreht der wind auf westliche richtungen
die temperaturen sinken auf +3 bis -2
grad es kann also auch über die zahl auf
den straßen an der nordsee ist es ein
bisschen milder und dort gibt es auch
einige winter gewittern morgen vormittag
gibt es noch ein paar letzte schauer
hier im nordosten dann wird es
freundlich und erst am nachmittag kommen
dann die dichtere wolken mit regen hier
in der nordsee heran am sonnigsten würz
morgen zwischen dem oberrhein und dem
alpenrand bei temperaturen von drei bis
neun grad das tief roxana wird dann am
sonntag weiter in richtung südosten
ziehen es fällt viel regen teils auch
schnee dabei und es wird stürmisch
ruhiger wird dann zum dienstag guten
abend